la sphère omar raddad son jardinier
marocain accusé d'avoir tué sa patronne
ghislaine marchal en 91 connaît un
nouveau rebondissement plus de dix ans
après le meurtre un étrange témoin vient
en effet de faire des révélations pour
le moins troublantes selon lui la riche
héritière aurait été assassinée par des
adeptes de la secte de l'ordre du temple
solaire
les explications de pascal justice ce
témoin surprise s'appelle guy morin il
s'est manifesté spontanément auprès du
parquet de grasse le 28 décembre dernier
soit plus de dix ans après le meurtre de
ghislaine marchal
il affirme que la riche héritière
retrouvée assassinée au pied de la
célèbre inscription omar m'a tuer
appartenait depuis 82 à l'ordre du
temple solaire
cette secte est connu pour les massacres
suicides collectifs de 94 et 97 selon
lui ghislaine marchal aurait été
assassiné en juin 91
parce qu'elle ne voulait plus financer
la sex guy morin affirme avoir conduit
trois membres de lo ts le jour du
meurtre devant le domicile de ghislaine
marchal dans une voiture immatriculée en
suisse un élément mis en avant par
l'ancien avocat d'omar raddad le
jardinier condamné pour ce crime dont
dossier un témoignage rapporté la
présence d'un véhicule automobile
immatriculée en suisse au portail de la
chamade dans une période contemporaine
de la mort de madame marchal et de son
meurtre dès lors il convient
effectivement que cette piste comme
toutes les autres soient fouillés parce
que décidément aujourd'hui encore cette
affaire ressemble garder son mystère
les déclarations de guy morin sont en
cours de vérification
mais enquêteurs et magistrats restent
sceptiques ce témoin a eu de nombreux
démêlés avec la justice et les membres
de la secte qu'il met en cause sont
décédés cette histoire du temple solaire
est à la fois ridicule grotesque est
démenti par tout ce qu'a établi le
dossier d'instruction qui a conduit à la
condamnation d'omar raddad tout ce qu'on
peut dire c'est que c'est la
médiatisation faite autour de marc
adapte médiatisation habile qui fait
qu'on peut éprouver un doute mais encore
une fois il ya dans le dossier intel
socle d'évidence que même s'il y avait
nouveau procès de marc à date je ne
doute pas de ce que serait le verdict de
cette nouvelle cour d'assises omar
raddad le jardinier a toujours clamé son
innocence mais il a été condamné pour ce
meurtre à 18 ans de réclusion criminelle
libéré en 98 après sept ans de prison il
attend aujourd'hui une éventuelle
révision de son procès